[Music]
the biggest example of a change in men's
lives and men's gendered behavior in the
definition of manhood is right now in
the transformation of fatherhood you
know what we're seeing now is just this
it's it's changing thousands of years of
history I remember when my kids were
young this was years ago if I couldn't
go out you know or do something or go to
a meeting some night because I was
looking after my kids people would say
oh you're babysitting tonight or or they
say oh great how much you help out with
your kids
and I'd be really pissed off I'd be
thinking I know babysit my own kids I
don't help out I'm a parent
well that was still a bit unusual back
then but now when I talk to young
fathers in their 20s in their 30s they
wouldn't have no one would dare say to
them you're babysitting you're helping
out mmm increasingly young fathers are
saying I'm striving to be an equal
parent I'm striving to take on half of
the care work in my home I'm striving to
take on half of the housework now it's
still unequal in our homes it's still an
equal but increasingly we're seeing men
doing more and more and more of that now
the significance of this is huge this is
perhaps the single most important thing
for gender quality of the workplace for
equal pay because it's because women are
burdened with you know childcare and
housework that that they take longer
offer for parental leaves they're the
ones tending to to you know to take off
work if their kid is sick that women
can't advance in the workforce as far
women don't go for that promotion women
don't travel as much for work and so
forth so with men doing half of the care
work it's going to be a major boost to
women's empowerment to equal pay it's
also an all the research tells us this
is great for children for children's
emotional development and well-being but
we also know this is good for men and
one of the biggest things is this to be
a successful caregiver you got to be
empathetic and you got to be empathetic
because a little kid a baby can't talk
and when they can start talking they
can't express
their motions so a parent has to feel
what a baby feels so think about it
think about if for thousands of years in
some cultures men haven't been doing the
primary childcare it means that men have
become less empathetic than we could be
part of the definition of manhood hasn't
been how feely and connected you are
that's how tough you are now this you
are so if we change fatherhood we're
changing something it's at the very
heart of our ideas of what it means to
be a man and if you're more empathetic
what does that mean what means there's
going to be less violence because it's
harder to cause harm to someone if you
can feel the pain you're causing it's
it's going to be a huge boost to
leadership I'm speaking last year in
Singapore to a group of bankers these
were bankers both from Asia and in
Europe and this one senior vice
president of a major British bank who
was in charge of all of Asia for this
Bank
started speaking and he said every
morning he said I make breakfast for my
kids I take them to school then I get to
work he said around 9:00 o'clock all the
bankers in the room laughs you know this
is not bankers hours and then he says
this is really important to my wife and
her career
this is really important to my children
and this is really important to me and
then he paused he said something that I
think is floored the audience he said
and this has made me a better leader I
can listen better
I can understand differences better I'm
more responsive to different needs I'm
more empathetic it's made him a better
leader so this is one example about the
about the really the demolition of some
of our traditional ideas of what it
means to be a man and it means hard work
for men it's a tough job being a parent
as any parent knows but it's also a
great blessing to men and I think it's a
great blessing to women and children as
well
[Music]